en bolivia la situación sanitaria es
crítica este miércoles frente a la
explosión de contagios en el país las
tres ciudades más importantes decidieron
cancelar todos los permisos ya emitidos
para la celebración de las fiestas de
fin de año la paz el alto pero también
cochabamba no tuvieron otra opción
frente a los casi 5.000 casos de kobe 19
diarios registrados por el ministerio de
salud boliviano un triste récord que no
se había superado desde mayo cuando el
país contaba cada día con más de 3000
casos estamos en escalada de la cuarta
ola están incrementando los casos y esto
se debe también y queremos saludar a los
servicios departamentales de salud por
haber cumplido las directrices que hemos
establecido en la última reunión que
hemos tenido frente a esa situación el
gobierno decretó la obligación de
presentar a partir del primero de enero
un carné de vacunación al día o una
prueba pcr negativa para ingresar a los
sitios de aglomeración de personas
bancos iglesias transportes mercados
deberán exigir a la entrada esos nuevos
requisitos los antivacunas bolivianos
salieron a las calles para protestar en
la paz y en el alto vamos a continuar en
las calles vamos a continuar hasta
lograr la abrogación y también hasta
lograr que se desprenda toda la
vacunación en territorio boliviano
generando algunos disturbios en ciertos
centros de vacunación nos vinieron a
pedirnos o físicamente quisieron
llevarse en las pruebas y las vacunas de
acá intentaron
a pedir a mis compañeras
hostigaron porque querían destrozar el
punto de vacunación y el punto de prueba
alrededor del 47% de los bolivianos ya
cuenta con una primera dosis y aunque
suramérica es la región más vacunada del
mundo se registraron las peores tasas de
mortalidad durante la pandemia